this is a story of when I realized why I
don't date white guys see in the past it
was a long string of Latinos and a
Korean and that didn't work out and I'm
missing out on a whole dating pool it's
always like imma open it up on OkCupid
let's do a white guy but I didn't figure
out my limits with white guys until my
third date with this guy Jim his real
name wasn't Jim but it was basically Jim
my parents were totally right the piano
lessons really did pay off so we're not
gonna tell him that the ring I mean I
think me being a professional musician
might tip them off yeah during the walk
I could feel him making a move but it
wasn't ready so as he was leaning in I
blocked him yep these plants aren't
native to California right hey let's
stop by my house it's on the way to
lunch let me show you those jazz records
in his defense we were actually talking
about his jazz records Jim makes a
beeline to his bedroom as I follow him I
see something out of the corner of my
eye
set a decorative samurai swords in that
moment a rush of memories snap in he did
tell me on our first date that he taught
English in Japan
and oh right he did tell me on our
second date that he took Mandarin
Chinese classes what was I thinking he
wants to add me to his collection of
decorative oriental objects you know
maybe it's just the one thing
what is if they say once is an accident
twice is a coincidence but three times
it's an enemy action I mean even my
extra Chinese immigrant parents house
had three fewer calligraphy Scrolls than
this guy and in that moment of panic I
imagined that all Jim wanted was someone
in that bedroom wearing a silky kimono
robe chopsticks in her hair and ribbon
dancing for him because let's be honest
the only two subpopulations of people
that I could possibly date who would
have that many Chinese calligraphy
Scrolls on their walls would be number
one real Asian gangster AZN pride
gangster dudes who have these girls uh
neurotic Lee because that shit's
beautiful and the second group owners of
Chinatown curio gift shops who lack
storage I knew the day was over
but I still wanted that Vietnamese food
that Jin said was so good I'm at the
front door and as I'm putting on my
shoes because of course hey what's that
oh that's just the culmination of my
entire music career in the middle of
this plaque was a photo of him shaking
the hand of an old important white guy
and Jim is wearing a blue silk [ __ ]
jacket for the biggest moment of Jim's
entire career he wanted to look like
Jackie Chan that was it I was like I'm
done with white land I could see the
bridge to white land and it looks really
great on the other side with their high
cheekbones j.crew outfits and potato
salad but I was done at first I thought
you know what I'm a bomb this bridge to
white land
no Jenny shall pass and then I realized
it's not that I shouldn't date any white
guys it's that I should not date a white
guy who's more Asian
than me
[Music]
you